you're talking earlier about uh juice
world juicer obviously
one of them ones uh gone too soon rp
juicer
uh the first thing to take me to the
chain smoker's house
you went to the chainsmokers crib yeah
they asked for spraying me with water
guns to see while i was asleep i woke up
my man y'all last tweaking boy [ __ ] is
how i'm doing what's that what's that
first of all tell me this story how did
you end up with juice roll going to the
chainsmokers house because i was in a
mystic um i was like um lady was
shopping and [ __ ] like that right they
like had a lot of deals on the table and
[ __ ]
and i went to link up with my boy g
money and baby them because they was
trying to snap me and [ __ ]
and uh they flew me to l.a or not i went
to their career but [ __ ] i was out there
for them with them for a couple days and
[ __ ]
and me and juice was chilling juice took
me to the studio um
young thug and then we left the studio
for one young thug and thank god then we
went to the chain smoker's crib
and bro we got there they were sitting
up in that [ __ ] just chopping it
up and [ __ ]
somebody let's go play laser tag it all
type of [ __ ] they was tweaking i fell
asleep knocked out on that [ __ ] they
just spray me with water guns while i
sleep i wake up man y'all ass tweaking
boy white boys better
smack the [ __ ] out yeah white boy humor
is different man yeah you hang out with
enough white people you get immune to
some interesting humor no but i i love
white guys you know what i'm saying
possibly
i [ __ ] i [ __ ] with a free i got a couple
of white friends called mexican friends
you know just a couple that's all you
need you know so yeah
how was so you would juice were pretty
tight
yeah yeah we was good we was getting
tight i ain't gonna lie like you know i
was gonna need here wake up and be like
come on jay let's go ride the dirt bike
so let's go play the xbox folks was like
he was grown but he was like always on
some activity kid [ __ ] right
no folks he was young man that's what
people forget like he was such a
prolific artist but he was barely got to
live a lot of his life you know what i'm
saying yeah he was on some young kids
[ __ ] too